[Music]
it's been a crazy week in america let's
find out what happened
the white house announced this week that
vice president kamala harris tested
positive for kovit 19. even crazier this
is how she told biden we did it we did
it joe
[Music]
former white house coronavirus response
coordinator dr debra burks said this
week that she was quote paralyzed when
donald trump suggested injecting bleach
to treat covid also paralyzed everyone
who took his advice
a bride in florida and her caterer were
arrested last week because they
allegedly served wedding guests food
laced with marijuana guests became
suspicious when the bride and her mom
got along
[Applause]
in honor of second chance month
president biden commuted the jail
sentences of 75 people this week and
gave three full pardons and
i thought you know what if biden can
give out second chances then why can't i
so in the spirit of second chance month
here are some things i'm going to give a
second chance to
time shares country music microsoft zoom
oversized jeans undersized jeans elliott
you mean jerry curls halle berries
catwoman pants that dip off to become
shorts your cousin's mixtape hyper
colored shirts
young sheldon old sheldon little mama
new coke bangs the phrase you're so 2000
and late learning how to dougie laser
disc crystal pepsi slap bracelets and
finally joe biden
hold on
what
what does joe biden need a second chance
for
for getting up the stairs
[Laughter]
oh boy oh i love it
so much i love it it's beautiful
a new report has found that in the 17th
and 18th centuries faculty staff and
leaders at harvard university enslaved
more than 70 people even crazier the
report was written by their janitor
how do you like them apples
slavery how do you like them
now pick them
have a good night everybody
went out on a real high note
according to a new report the country's
best public high school is virginia's
thomas jefferson high school for science
and technology while the most terrifying
high school is the one from euphoria
a restaurant worker at the chain
longhorn steakhouse recently grilled her
millionth steak and to her i say well
done
[Applause]
the fast food chain jack-in-the-box will
reportedly start using a robot to flip
burgers also using a robot to get the
job done your girlfriend
and finally today was world wish day and
i wish
a mother would
and that was the monologue did you guys
like the monologue
i like it
thank you well if you like the monologue
then here's a video of me writing it
[Applause]
that's real
in other news april is national stress
awareness month now since high stress
levels can be detrimental to your health
it's important to deal with stress in
healthy ways
now i myself have a lot of stress and a
first step to combating it is
identifying the stressors in my life a
few of mine are working long hours
public speaking loans and
mike's disgusting rat tail
what
like does no one in your house own
scissors a mirror
eyes
you look like you taught four teenage
turtles ninjutsu
you look like the world's worst sequel
to ratatouille standing over there with
your anakin skywalker looking ass
it's like oh man oh
health can also create stress things
like worrying about the health of loved
ones weight gain body image serious
illness or
even just the strain of looking at
mike's
grotesque rat tail your barber must hate
you do you hang that thing down from a
tower for a prince to climb up every
night
you look like a poorly made cup and ball
game
you look like neo getting plugged into
the matrix i hate you amber please stop
you stop stressing me out
because stress can come from all sorts
of things
getting laid off having money problems
issues at work or at home limiting
stressors is important you have to take
some weight off your shoulders
or in mike's case off the back of his
head
tell me something is that how you have
sex with other navi
you look like a poor man's pooty tank
do you have a girlfriend
leave him
amber
amber stop geez
okay i'll stop
just like we should stop engaging with
stressors in our
lives one way to alleviate stress is to
cut out things that worry you or make
you uneasy
oh what you're gonna say i can alleviate
stress by cutting out my disgusting rat
tail yay no
but i was gonna say i can alleviate
stress by cutting you and your poor hair
choices out of my life you look like
every man buns shitty antagonist
you look like brett michael's only black
friend
if i pull on it like a string do you say
there's a snake in my boot
your hair makes rosa park sad
ah
is this better are you happy now
actually i was kind of getting used to
it
what what
moving on
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
green is back in the news remember her
she's the lady who made headlines when
she yelled at representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez through the mail slot on
her office door
alexandria ocagio cortez i'm an american
citizen i pay your salary through the
taxes that you collect from me through
the irs
if you want to be a big girl you need to
get rid of your diaper and come out and
be able to talk to the american citizens
instead of having to use a flap a little
flap
well last week there was a hearing to
determine whether she should be
disqualified from seeking reelection
because of her public statements about
the january 6th insurrection during the
trial she was questioned about calling
speaker pelosi a traitor here's a clip
in fact you think that speaker pelosi is
a traitor to the country right
uh you're i'm not answering that
question it's speculation you've said
that having you miss green that she's a
traitor to the country no i haven't said
that okay
put up planets exhibit five please
oh no wait
hold on now
that's some big oh they got receipts
energy
looks like marjorie taylor green got
herself in some serious trouble amber
amber roofing oh no
what is it marjorie taylor green is at
the door again
that's right i'm back and i'm suing you
for defamation
why
because you're making me look bad by
accusing me of saying things i actually
said
and then showing videos of me actually
saying them
marjorie if you said those things aren't
you just defaming yourself oh that's
some classic leftist trickery
you're like one of those mean jedi's
doing mind tricks on those poor
stormtroopers
the stormtroopers were the bad guys oh
you hear that america amber hates the
troops
get the hell out of here you can't get
rid of me that easy i brought back up
hello
hello
hello
hello
no you brought representative madison
cawthorn and texas senator ted cruz
i sure did we're like the three amigos
but if they were white the three amigos
were white
what is wrong with you
let me in there
listen i will not let you cancel the
three amigos
madison cawthorn calm down sir oh what
are you going to say next that i accused
republicans of having orgies
that's exactly what you did
stop twisting my words i do not love
orgies with old guys i didn't say you
did
no well good because that barely sounds
hot to me right now
you are gross
what's gross is how you and the woke mom
are trying to twist my words to make it
sound like i love orgies when i've
barely even been to enough orgies to
form an opinion
uh
just go to the green room
what's the green room oh is that where
the sex party is there is no sex party
oh well sure not till i get there yeah
stop attacking him oh shut up ted cruz
oh you'd love for me to shut up so you
can make it look like i want to see
mickey and pluto get it on
you said that in real life on the radio
and now the liberal media wants to make
it seem like all i do is think about
mickey and pluto doing it doggy style
please say less
oh sweaty and oily stop
and pluto has like really sick abs wait
okay let me get this straight the three
of you are mad at me and the rest of the
media for making you look bad that's
correct when all i did was repeat things
that you actually said in real life in
public also correct y'all need to leave
right now
good luck trying to get rid of us it's
our constitutional right to yell at you
through a mail slot
have you read the constitution uh it's
on my to-do list oh goodness look
you are a [ __ ]
i am amora
you want to leave and take your
goofy-ass friends with you i want to
leave and take my goofy-ass friends with
me
oh goofy's ass
i should have tried that sooner
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you